ces clichés sont la mémoire de la france
ouvrière et immigrés avec sont noyés son
appareil photo gérald bloncourt à
immortaliser cette france des années 50
ils les quelques 200000 photos dont
certaines sont déjà dans les musées il y
as étant nous l'avions croisé à fort de
france lors d'une exposition de ses
oeuvres
gérald bloncourt se définissait comme le
plus ancien exilés haïtiens
il avait été déchu de sa nationalité est
contraint à l'exil en 1946 à l'époque ce
jeune militant communiste que l'on voit
ici aux côtés de jacques stephen alexis
était le des meneurs d'une insurrection
connu en haïti sous le nom des cinq
glorieuses cinq journées
révolutionnaires qui devait conduire à
la chute du pouvoir en place
celui d'elie les scoops nous avons créé
le fameux journal la ruche qui a été
l'étincelle
nous avons mis tout le monde dehors des
masses de gens et nous avons obtenu tête
et aux forces de répression et en cinq
jours nous avons obligé le dictateur à
s'enfuir seulement il a été
immédiatement suivie par un coup d'état
la junte militaire le welt les colonels
level magloire et l'avons peu de pouvoir
appuyer par les américains et ça a été
la répression
c'est un la martinique que le jeune
blond cours trouvent refuge
il a 20 ans et bénéficie de la
protection d'amis de ses parents et
d'aimé césaire c'est ce dernier
d'ailleurs qui facilite son départ à
paris ou le devient photographe peintre
graveur poète sans jamais oublier son
haïti chérie dans le ventre de ce pays
sur la peau de ce pays j'étends non non
mais os est à voir dans la mienne j'ai
ma main ouverte au monde pour mon pays
gérald bloncourt m'a remis les pieds en
haïti qu'après la chute des duvalier en
1986 il a mené son succès le combat pour
faire juger le dictateur haïtien
cet ardent militant es artiste engagée
aurait eu 92 ans le 4 novembre prochain